- When you put a baby,
and discussion of politics
together, you're just
- Oh yeah
- Guaranteed to not have sleep.
(upbeat music)
So today, I'm gonna be
partnered with someone
who identifies as conservative.
- She happens to be a
liberal, and so we're gonna
both jointly take care
of a robot baby together.
I've never held a baby before,
I mean I held it one time maybe.
- An actual baby toddler?
Yes, but baby? No.
(upbeat music)
- [Barrett] I do also know that
(robot baby cooing)
- No.
- Oh no. Should we?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Okay.
(robot baby crying)
You gotta do the bouncy, yeah.
- Why are you crying?
- It's okay. Oh.
(robot baby stops crying)
- Oh, that's what it needed.
And that was only like
the first ten seconds.
- It's stressful, that
was kinda stressful.
- We're so screwed.
We will be receiving a
score, a percentage score
from one to a hundred.
Hopefully we do well.
Are people gonna think that we're crazy
for carrying this thing around?
- Yes, let's embrace it.
This is the car seat of the future guys.
- (chuckles) It's not, please
don't ever do this at home.
I'm gonna see Barrett tonight,
so we will reconnect then.
Bye. See ya tonight.
- Bye, see ya Michael.
- So I'm gonna have to
go into the grocery store
with this one here, and
I'm kinda concerned.
When we were together it was much more fun
to see everyone else's reactions,
but then I feel--
- Alone it's awkward.
- When I went alone it's
like you just wanna be like,
just disregard this lump
that's under my shirt.
(robot baby crying)
You're crying, at least it's happening now
and not in the grocery store.
Why does it shit so much?
- Father of the year
- [Natalie] Oh yeah, what up.
- We've talked about Trump,
and I didn't actually vote for Trump.
- We're about to go on YouTube
and look at some stuff that he said.
Makes you tick or what makes you believe--
- Yeah, but like--
- In what you believe in?
- We kinda came around to issues,
like I'm trying to say something,
but I don't know quite how to say it yet,
and then we kept talking and it was like
okay now I kinda know,
once everything filled in.
- I started to talk about Gavin McInnes.
- I do agree with some of
the positions he takes,
but he's going about it like a dick.
- He thinks he's funny
though, I mean I've adjusted,
(stammering)
but I don't agree.
- I can take the perspective of someone
that believes otherwise,
and it's like, why would I?
- Why would I want to if
I were not in agreement?
- We realized that afterwards,
we have been talking
for like a solid, 11, 12,
one, two, five straight hours.
I'm alive, she's alive.
If he wasn't keeping us up,
we were keeping each other up.
- Yeah so, it was gonna happen anyways.
Every time I've had a
conversation with someone
who doesn't have similar
beliefs, things get really heavy.
But, I actually left this
conversation, pretty darn happy.
It's 4:30 a.m. why is
my baby still eating?
Oh there you go, yeah, ooh
look at that, look at you.
Yeah this kid is gonna
go up this entire hill.
Yeah he's gonna carry him up,
so I just have to carry my water bottle.
In this situation we found
out yes, we are striving
towards the same things, we
go about it in a different way
and I think when we talked about it
in the context of Michael,
like oh if our child
ended up, growing up, you know as gay.
So, would it make any difference to you
if our baby, he grew up
and he came out as gay,
would that impact you personally?
- Some people are assholes,
they're gonna do things
based on what they know.
You can take it personally
or you can just move on.
- He never used his tone of voice
in a way that was
discriminative or put me down,
and I've been in that
situation many times before.
So if that didn't occur, I
don't think I would've listened
I don't think I would've cared.
If he decided that he wanted
to go and advocate something
that wasn't what you believed in,
would you be like, do what you wanna do,
but I'm not gonna support you.
- A lot of people do
jump to the conclusion,
or to certain assumptions,
without enough data.
And I think that's important for you
to make you're own decisions.
To speak on the Black Lives Matter thing,
there are issues that are
still needing to be addressed,
so those are real and if my son feels,
and really takes those on as his own,
I'm for that, at least
he's doing something.
- [Natalie] (laughs) you literally look
like your working out with Michael.
- (chuckles) it's heavy.
I was mid-shower, and baby
Michael started crying.
- So I guess I'm not
going to just nap anymore.
Baby is not burping and it's been like,
straight up 20 minutes. He's so much more
of a mom than I am. I just
thought about single motherhood
a lot, whenever he was gone.
(laughing)
You know if I don't get married
I'll just adopt a kid, it'll be fine.
(robot baby crying)
Can you give me the bottle again?
- [Barrett] Yeah.
(robot baby stops crying)
- I fucking hate this baby.
(both laughing)
- My beliefs, I'm sticking to my guns,
in terms of like my conservative views,
and Natalie is sticking to her guns.
Through all of that, one,
we were so respectful
to each other, and I
was able to kind of get
where she was coming from, as I do think
that she really did get
where I was coming from.
- It's kind of amazing having a one-on-one
time with somebody who
is willing to listen
and willing to evaluate
your values and beliefs,
in a non-critical way,
cause I genuinely believe
that politics make up who you are.
- Talking to her at length,
really made me understand
the other side a lot more.
Having something like this
medium, like in a baby
to care for, puts stuff in perspective.
Like there's policy and there's all these
different kinds of things,
but when we have something
that's right here, that we
have to take care of together.
Those things end up being
kind of meaningless in a way.
- Okay so we're here it's the end.
It's 10:00 p.m. which means baby is off.
Which means I can now
- Stop! Stop! Stop (chuckles) no.
92%!
- Whoa, we got an A
minus, is that an A minus
or is that, that's on the verge of A
- I don't know.
- We had so many
discussions where our desire
was really to find a solution, rather than
to continuously butt heads over
a subject that we don't agree with.
- Whether I may not
agree with it right now,
through more conversation, you never know.
Like, you have to be at least open,
and not closed-minded to
accept some other way to do it.
It is all about common
understanding, and empathy,
you're being able to kind of see it
from the other sides perspective.
I do think if that stuff is in place,
it does actually work out.
- It's kind of nice to
be able to prove that,
and tell people that, what the media says,
about the two different groups or whatever
sides that there are, it
may not necessarily be true.
- Yeah.
- That's what I felt like
this project did for me
or for us. Can I do it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
(laughing)
say goodbye.
- He's so sad.
(robot baby crying)
I don't think it's working.
- [Barrett] No, just keep patting him.